the Joe Rogan experience this brings me
to but is a subject that keeps getting
brought up nowadays is universal basic
income with the oncoming yeah apocalypse
of automation this is how it's being
portrayed by Andrew yang who's running
for president and I sat down talked with
him about it's very compelling and he's
a very smart guy and he's an
entrepreneur himself and when he starts
talking about automation and how it's
going to just eliminate massive amounts
of jobs and leave people stranded what
do you when I know you're a guy who
thinks about the future I'm gonna be a
popular point of view on this I don't
think it's a non solution to a non
problem mmm mmm and I mean that in the
sense that automation has been happening
as a dot of time man when electricity
came along that put a lot of people out
of work did it right a lot of people
carrying buckets of water and you know
lighting lamps and all those kinds of
things and this was the concern with
factories as well perhaps everything
literally every single thing that comes
even a printing press absolutely and
what it does is it frees people up for
new creative work so the question is not
is automation going to eliminate jobs
there is no finite number of jobs when
I'm like sitting around dividing up the
same jobs that were around since the
Stone Age
so obviously new jobs are being created
and they're usually better jobs more
creative jobs so the question is how
quickly is this transition going to
happen and what kinds of jobs will be
eliminated what kinds of jobs will be
created it's impossible looking forward
to predict what kinds of jobs will be
created if I told you 10 years ago that
podcaster was gonna be a job or that you
know playing video games is gonna be a
job or commentating on video games gonna
be a job you would have laughed me out
of the room those are the nonsense jobs
but yet here we are so society will
always create new jobs civilization
creates new jobs but it's impossible to
predict what those jobs are so the
question is how quickly is that
transition happening well the reality is
even though everybody keeps talking
about this automation apocalypse we're
at a record low unemployment explain
that where's the transition Donald Trump
that's hard all I'm saying is it's it's
it's I don't see it in the numbers I
don't see it actually happening the
question is how quickly can you retrain
people so it's an education problem the
problem in the ubi there's a couple of
problems at UVI
one is you're creating a straight you
creating a slippery slide transfer
straight into socialism right the moment
people can start voting themselves money
combined with the democracy well it's
just a matter of time before the bottom
fifty one votes themselves everything
the top forty line yeah and it's just it
and by the slippery slope fallacy is not
a fallacy and I know people like saying
that but they haven't thought it through
but the moment you start having a direct
transfer mechanism like that in a
democracy you're basically doing it with
capitalism which is the engine of
economic growth you're also forcing the
entrepreneurs out or telling them not to
come here the estimate I saw for 15k a
year basic income for everybody would be
three-quarters of current GDP and of
course GDP was shrinking responses all
the entrepreneurs fled so you would
essentially bankrupt the country another
issue at UVI is that people who are down
on their luck they're not looking for
handouts it's not just about money it's
also about status it's about meaning and
the moment I start giving money to you
and put you on the dole I've lowered
your status I've made you a second-class
citizen so I have to give you meaning
and meaning comes to education and
capability I have you have to teach a
man to fish not to basically throw your
rotting leftover carcasses that haven't
say here eat the scraps so it doesn't
solve the meaning problem and lastly
it's nonsense to hand 15k out to
everybody you wanna means-test people
there's no reason to give it to you and
me so you end up back towards the
welfare system where you do have to
figure out who needs it and who doesn't
so I think the better route is that we
actually establish a set of basic
substance services that you have to have
and we provide those in abundance to
technology-based automation so get basic
housing get basic food get basic
transportation get high-speed internet
access get a phone in your pocket those
are the kinds of things you want to give
people and finally in terms of the rate
of automation I think we can educate
people very quickly one of the myths
that we have today is that adults can't
be re-educated we view education is this
thing where you go to school you come
out when you're out of college and
you're done
no more education well that's wrong you
have all these great online boot camps
and coding schools coming up they're
ones that will even pay you to go there
now
you can educate people and mass and you
can educate them into creative
professions
[Applause]